on a une grande duplicité dans le
discours des politiques depuis plus de
30 ans sur l'industrie d'un côté vous
avez effectivement des ministres qui
quelles que soient leurs tendances vont
s'emparer d'un cas extrêmement
médiatique pour penser que leurs courbes
en fait de popularité sera corrélé au
nombre d'interventions qui feront sur le
sujet et qui derrière en fait ne font
absolument rien pour l'industrie
française depuis 79 81 1979 80 on a une
inflexion on a un choix politique
notamment de la part de bercy pour les
services on a une préférence française
pour les services qu'est ce qu'on a fait
on a surchargé nos entreprises
industrielles en termes de taxes on a
des taxes à la production d'environ 64
milliards qu'on paye en plus en france
par rapport en allemagne donc des taxes
production ces taxes hors bilan or bien
en amont du bilan qui se font décorrélée
justement de votre vote bénéfices et à
côté de ça pendant que justement les
ministres continuent d'appuyer sur la
pompe fiscale vous avez des grandes
déclarations d'intention à la télé ça
peut pas ça peut pas marcher